look who fritzy tracked down it's David
Feherty NBC Sports golf analyst host of
fat and he live on the Golf Channel
David what are you doing in Mexico and
I'm sitting on a card to the TV compound
surrounded by I'm not sure well don't
drink the water I think the food's okay
yeah so we have me a WGC Mexico
championship there and you got a pretty
good lineup no Dustin Johnson's down
there who else is playing how was South
Korea colder than the Summer Games
it was brutally cold 35 below at times
up to L and the windchill I really don't
understand by the coast it wasn't so bad
yeah but you know the sea was still
frozen in places so I mean that's that's
cold
ferdi live coming up you've got Ricky
Fowler and Jack Nicklaus as the show
debuts a new multi guest format in 2018
who else is going to be who's on your
wish list here if we're sitting down
talking golf who's the one guy you
haven't gotten yet first I got Ray Allen
John Wester and Mark Calcavecchia in the
show okay Billy Horschel cat is there
and Kevin prisoner and you see Billy
Horschel time to rise which was a
hysterical Justin Leonard and Tom lemon
which was it will surprise you wish list
jeez Bill Murray Tiger Woods
well I'm surprised you haven't gotten
either one of those with your
relationship certainly with tiger has it
just been you know not in the same place
at the same time you know I want them to
be who I remember him being growing up
you know the kids with a great smile
that love to play golf that would good
for Ron tell jokes sort of thing I need
them to be a little vulnerable when it
comes you know just to show the human
side of him that I knows there but so
few people about himself over the last
few years but you used to have fun you
know we always look at Tiger and it
feels like he's very serious but didn't
you have like a whoopee cushion or you
know something that sound nice why do we
care so much about Tiger why we still
care I think we care because he
obviously cares so much you know if he
didn't love the game he wouldn't be here
doing this he adores playing golf and
you can see it and you know people's
memories are short leash you know I
think it's been recently nothing of the
tiger thing where you can see the crud
out there beige mean it's justice it's
the way yesterday it's amazing all he's
going to do is set foot on a golf course
and you know that movie atmosphere is
still theirs and mighty play well you
know I think that's that's why people
love them what was your take on Justin
Thomas getting the fan thrown out yeah
you know I just got back from killing
Chang and caught the end about it
Sports Center
let me get this straight the guy was
sort of stalking him over a period of
two or three holds these comments were
made is that right yeah I think he said
I hope you put it in the water I hope
you put it in the bunker so yeah he was
it was not part of the the gallery
supporting Justin Thomas that's for sure
yes well you know it's time to say what
you want you know I think that's that's
okay yeah but can you get him thrown do
you think this makes it worse for Justin
Thomas as he moves forward or makes it
better but he's strong enough mentally
to get through this sort of thing we saw
Sergio years ago his trigger trouble
yeah we're the progeny in New York we're
finding how many times I mean that's a
tough thing to get three but these these
guys that know they want to play golf
now they love to play golf for a living
personally then I want to see a little
bit of finish you know everywhere I
don't need to see it all every week but
I certainly might see courage heading in
that direction
yeah I don't know you know even the
Ryder Cup you're not really saying
something negative to the opposing
country it's more of you're trying to
pump up your own country here that this
is rare when unless you know you're
always walking with these golfers maybe
you hear more of this than you know we
hear when we're watching on TV I didn't
know if you heard like if you when
you're walking with these golfers and
you're with the marquee group you know
do you hear heckling
oh yes yeah absolutely I mean Tiger has
put up with it for years years people
yelling and screaming timers going off
and when no one is out it like like
tiger monster here we could you get it
on the regular basis with other with
other groups as well you know somebody
get to say I'm just on a camera button
or something said there is only a push
hey have fun down there and we'll talk
to you soon good luck with ferret alive
all right all right
David Feherty NBC golf analyst and host
of ferreting got Jack Nicklaus coming up
Rickie Fowler as well
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]